I'm packing lunch my bestie who's a huge
Studio chili fan and here's what I need
so I'm using chicken thighs and
seasoning with curry powder sugar grated
garlic and ginger soy sauce and sake
then I'm gonna let this marinate for an
hour I was having some trouble deciding
what to make for her so I used Vada Tui
which is basically an AI powered sous
chef and you can get it by downloading
the tasty app ask it a question and
it'll give you some recipe options and
that's how I came up with this Japanese
Fried Chicken Bento so I packed
everything up in this little lunch box
for her to take and I'm pairing this
with a side of broccolini